hi guys and welcome to a new episode of
off the rails
uh what we what you're seeing me on is
the four thousand dollar love bot we
bought for
love so that you can participate in the
show today ila is
out of the office so i'm in the teddy
fresh office and i'm here
to check on everybody hi lina are you on
task today
yes very much so absolutely let me lower
this a bit
just so i can be on eye level with you i
don't want you to feel that i'm towering
over you but that we're equals
oh wow it's fast now pick up some speed
eh
andrew just checking up on you make sure
you're working
everything okay great you didn't close
anything on the browser
when i approached did you you saw that
i'm just observing what are you trying
to hide it looks
it looks weird dude because you're
looking down
i gotta use the restroom excuse a little
privacy please
someone want to play ping-pong with me
he's okay hey
look who's back hey hey hey
and he's off the rails this is our first
official
number one baby off the rails
and i'm telling you guys ela's not here
and
i'll be honest some of the crew member
is afraid that i'm gonna be getting
seriously injured today we're so off the
rails
it's gonna be a literal train wreck
what we've got planned is the love bot
which you guys
have met we're gonna have a collision
course we're gonna see what this bot can
do
and then once love is done navigating
that i'm gonna rip it apart on the
gatsby
we got a little some jumps and stuff
it's gonna be pretty gnarly bro
jackass part five
off the rails
we got sued and now i'm going to the
hospital you just gonna be like what
have you done
yeah my goal off the rails only ends
when
either i'm hospitalized or
we're sued to the point of uh a judge
putting a
a conjunction on us what is that called
when the judge is like you you can't do
this anymore
injunction injunction that's it baby
that's the only way we're stopping
we got a lot of fun stuff here today
though um
coming up ian's beard
ian's been getting a lot of comments on
his beard so we're gonna have a whole
segment about
in stand up ian stand up
please stand up stand up here let's see
that we stand up
yeah ian looking like forrest gump who
just ran across country
what year is it and he's yeah
right exactly from jumanji
so ian what's going on with the beard i
mean let's come on
like just to clarify i know it looks
like [ __ ] don't worry i haven't
convinced myself you didn't say that
that this is a vibe i i told myself that
uh
when the pandemic started and we all
went inside
i was going to embrace that and just
see how nasty my hair and beard could go
yeah that's interesting because i saw
sam yesterday your girlfriend and she
said she lot she didn't mind it she even
said she liked it
i'm sure she really means that oh you
think she should
okay it seems sincere yeah it seems
sincere to me yeah
life was like a box itself of course
gunpowder looking
you never know what you're going to get
oh that's great
well apparently you posted a photo you
got a bunch of hate comments so we're
going to talk about that
i don't mind it though i think i could
use some some grooming but
like you know what i mean yeah
i mean now that we're back at work i was
planning on shaving it all off like the
social experiment is over
it's over i have so many questions for
you
but so we're going to be talking about
that may oh a mayo update
and actually the most exciting thing by
far
is that bts
korean pop superstars
the one and only now has a mcdonald's
meal you guys
no way
and get this here's the meal
it's chicken nuggets
it's french fries and it's a coke
innovative wow and it was um i'll be
honest with you guys i don't know if
it's
i don't know if i'm is it nine bucks
for the nugget meal now let me just say
this with peace and love
i look i've said things about bts in the
past that i deeply regret
they were xenophobic they were not they
were even i'll be honest dude it was
it wasn't cool what i said about about
bts
i've been listening to bts i've been
opening my mind and i am army now
that's why i bought we bought two of
these in support of army
and we're going to be reviewing them and
um
i'm so sorry to bts army i honestly i
don't ever wanna
i'm army guys i'm like signed up on the
forums
i've got my favorite one do you post
fan cams on twitter i have a yeah i have
a sp
i have a secret fan cam twitter account
that nobody knows about sick
and i i spam my own tweets with fan cams
you you said you have a favorite one
which one
um that's my favorite what was his name
v
oh that's the guy who speaks really good
english right i believe so
yeah and they do this what's up haters i
know what the [ __ ] i'm doing
they hate the heart right you see i
learned about them
i love k i love bts and all cultures
of the koreas specifically south korea
north korea is fine but i'm not
i love the people of north korea uh but
we don't stand kim jong-un i don't stand
kim jong-un
no i'm john no no no no no no no no no
no
anyway with that being said okay so
listen the me
this real special sauce of the meal is
that they got these special dipping
sauces
sweet chili and cajun now you know first
of all this
wouldn't be off the rails if i wasn't
eating stuffing my [ __ ] face to be
honest with you guys i came in and i
already demolished the fries because i
was like oh [ __ ] this i'm not waiting
so this is very off the rails okay
trisha organizing me what was that i
hope that's not what that was so
now just just bear this in mind army
members who are watching
if i don't like this it doesn't mean i
don't like bts
i love bts and everything they stand for
and do
[Music]
but if i don't like this sauce please
don't cancel me
i'll try my best to like it though which
one are you hitting first so you guys
got your sauces back there
we're gonna do a team dipping dude i'm
not gonna hit the nuggies but i will try
it with some fries here yo
since when was a nuggy meal nine bucks
mcdonald's usually has a 20 piece for
five bucks
20 pieces for five what happened is it
the sauce is the sauce expensive
well that's just the nuggets for the
five bucks but still yeah i don't know
oh so you do have to pay extra for the
sauces so maybe there's a little extra
charge on the sass
okay whatever i just looked it up uh 10
piece
chicken mcnuggets at mcdonald's is 450
and that's just for the nuggets so if
you add the fries in the drink yeah i'm
about maybe what you talking about 30
dollars
20 dollars for five bucks that's
outrageous no just for the nuggets
though now no drink nobody
just refuted that that is wrong oh wait
a minute
no he's right the the 20 piece is only
five dollars the 10
is 450 and then you can get another 10
for another 50
that's why everybody's fat as [ __ ] they
want because if i knew that i'd be
getting those 20 pieces
every time i i apologize why are those
extra 10 nuggies were only worth 50
cents because like you said they want to
[ __ ] shove the [ __ ] but isn't that
right what does that say about the
actual cost of making these nuggies
where they're like it's worth it to give
them
double for 50 more yeah well
nobody said chicken whoa the highest
quality meat
all right so so bts army v we love v
v heart everything wow
v is uh one of the members oh dan oh
so ignorant i am ignorance so much to
learn dan he's
i'm not hating i just i literally don't
know the name of the members all right
i'm taking a taste of the cajun
how is cajun a south korean thing isn't
that like literally
and i'm like a american spice i
i mean yes but uh maybe just cajun
flavoring is popular over there i mean
korean food is popular over here so
you know it's a cultural exchange
let's [ __ ] go you're into it
it's like horseradishy it's a flavor you
don't expect to find in america
with the horseradish it's got a kick
there a little mustardy
i like that oh that is good yeah
approved wow dude i'll never forget good
dude i love the occasion bro
sensational no way no what this is the
best sauce ever
i'm trying
off of one bite it's perfect yeah fried
chicken wednesday baby
it is it is good hand to god is out of
this [ __ ] planet
[Music]
oh my god you guys
it's almost as good as their music
oh i'm not exaggerating this is so good
it's spicy it's horseradishy it's creamy
this is unbelievable i am i am blown
away by this cajun sauce
i'm into it now i see why so much more
i'm gonna come
you know it recalls the memory of whim
friend of the show justin roiland got
that
the szechuan sauce the szechuan sauce
right
said they talked about rick and morty
and then mcdonald's re-issued a couple
of szechuan bottles for him
do you think people have an amazing
marketing team by the way
mcdonald's yeah i mean i know they're
like huge but like
they're really good at marketing because
they sent him the szechuan bottle
and this like it looked like the nuclear
codes where you keep the nuclear codes
it was awesome anyway i tried the
szechuan sauce
i hated it horrible
this is the real [ __ ] deal
wow did you all get a taste of the of
the occasion
i have tasted the cajun and um i'm with
you i i'm not gonna go as far as to say
it's the best sauce i've ever had but it
but it's quite good i like it 10 out of
10.
i like it 10 out of 10. well we have
another sauce here i'm moving on to the
sweet chili which i don't expect to be
as good to be frank just based on the
look and consistency but
keep an open mind
very sweet that's pretty good too
bro it's not bad i'm they nailed it i'm
not
i'm not even going to complain bts
nailed it those south koreans know how
to eat
sauce sauce yes they do
that is honestly really good but i'm
cajun boy all the way
the cajun is better but the other one is
good oh my god
you guys if you think i'm just blowing
smoke up your ass
i'm shoveling it in my mouth yeah yeah
hila's not here to stop me
fire
was that that was that the semen pretty
sure that just screamed fire
yeah is that what that came from okay um
yeah no i'm impressed this is certainly
better than um
than the standard mcdonald's uh sauce
fare you know what i mean i know some
people are very much about the
mcdonald's barbecue sauce but i've
always felt barbecue sauce is
very lacking i like barbecue sauce in
the right conditions you know like on
grilled meat and stuff but
i'm not dipping my nugs in barbecue
sauce that to me is insane
that's what i do that's i'm not dipping
my nugs in barbecue sauce i'll take
ranch
i'll take ketchup you take ranch over
barbecue sauce on doggies
[ __ ] every day of the week so i don't
agree with ethanol what the
[ __ ] i'm with dan i'm a barbecue thank
you i'm disgusting i'm not for the ranch
the ranch is life dude i'll do whatever
bts is doing
i i i'm gonna come out of the closet
right now and let everybody know that i
i'm actually a ranch hater
me too buck ranch
awful one of the worst inventions
come at me what ranch wine sucks ass
it's a terrible sauce terrible dressing
i mean
i'll take basically any other salad
dressing over ranch on a salad
why it grosses me out too why i love
bran it's just
it's just it's so good it's
everything wrong with america distilled
into assault
okay stop dan so high mighty like you're
[ __ ] the
the pinnacle of health and beauty
it's just anyway what can i do well i
might what i'm not going to convince you
ranch is good and you don't like it i
mean you have bad taste what can i do
you know what i put on everything a guy
doesn't [ __ ] want barbecue sauce on
his nugs
like what it's blast for me anyway i was
honestly at first i was like mmm i don't
get it it's just a chicken nugget meal
but
for our mcdonald's commercial that's
right
i love them so much and i'm so excited
to share this with you we can't wait for
you to try and grasp we hope you're
ready to order the biggest meal
what's in the mirror chicken mango gas
fries and
coke it's just funny when they go
chicken nugget fries and coke i was like
i think that's the number five
already but it comes the question sauce
cajun sauce special cajun sauce and
sweet chili sauce
just for you
[Music]
these guys are amazing man they can sell
anything bro they're literally out here
selling chicken nugget meal
and like i saw number one trending on
twitter yesterday
everyone's buying chicken nuggets it's
already been on the menu for like
decades right so are you ready
here it is our mechanized our his shirt
so come click check it out and don't
forget to order your own bts
mia oh i didn't
there was in one promo video they go
because they're they're so like
healthy you know i was like my these
guys aren't eating like i don't i
feel like they probably don't eat
nuggies no they go there's ten
nuggies one for each member and three
left over
so each one of them is getting one
nugget i was like that sounds about
right
my fat ass is eating all 10 of them
there's like there's three left over
who's gonna get them just kidding
they're all gonna share
i was like oh my god is that how i'm
supposed to be eating one nugget
money even yeah
god i've been slipping lately i'm not
gonna lie uh
yesterday we had shake shack on the bus
tour
no good people don't know about that yet
here i think this is the one where they
say they're gonna share the nuggies
[Music]
yeah we're here for the bts meal
alcohol and fries
ten piece chicken nuggets
and one more thing
and cage yo this is insane yeah the
beast is gonna
pull those sauces out of the matrix
[Music]
dude i cannot believe they're just
selling a chicken nugget meal
this is amazing marketing bro i want to
do a meal it's just like
cheeseburger french fries diet coke
wasn't that basically uh travis scott's
remember
yeah no his was like was just a normal
meal too it was um do you have anything
special like extra pickles or some [ __ ]
ian what was it
yeah uh i don't remember exactly it was
a sprite
and a big mac i like how you don't get
to pick your own drink
either like it comes with a coke that's
it dude
[Laughter]
we should make our own crew meals well
you could customize it but yeah if you
just say like
i'm here to speak to captain jack then
there's no customizing
no they they didn't even acknowledge
that we tried saying yo what's up
captain jack they'd be like what
right ian ian went and tried that and
yeah we're just like what the [ __ ]
i did it i did on my own time and they
didn't had no idea what the [ __ ] it was
yeah they're like what the [ __ ] bro just
order
oh that's a training problem i suppose a
mcdonald's okay so what would our meal
be
i feel like my meal would be
the double quarter pander with cheese
hey come get the eathy meal double
quarter pounder with cheese
okay large size and because you're
packing on those calories we're gonna be
adding
a diet coke you know what it is
no substitute oh but here's the twist
okay what's the twist yeah
double quarter pounder with cheese no
onions
[Music]
taking things away it's the ethan meal
it's less than a normal meal
it's the eat the meal baby no onions no
onions just say ethan's saying you know
what the [ __ ] oh wait there's one more
twist
okay oh this is what cactus jack did a
little bit of ice
not a lot oh no extras oh yeah he was
extra ice that's right
he added bacon is what that was that was
the
the twist on his head over to mcdonald's
diet coke i am so excited no
ice half full
i like that at least with no ice you get
more soda no it's half full because i
don't like to drink at all
oh oh it's large size but half full
oh i haven't got another good one ethan
meal the bag comes with a ton of fries
on the bottom
[Music]
yeah but they're not free they just pour
some out
into the bag oh these aren't bonus fries
they pour them out into the bag
so your carton is half full
[Music]
i gotta say i'm not that impressed with
the ethan meal well i'm not that
impressed with any of these meals i know
i mean that's true
but it well the bts one these special
sauces
do kick it up enough okay here the ethan
meal comes with an
extra patty thrown into the bag
with no container or anything it's just
a patty
[Music]
and then they squirt ketchup into the
bag floating
it's just a soup it's just a mcdonald's
soup in your bag
tell them ethan sent you papa's in the
house
all right well i got to eat mcdonald's
so i guess that was worth it
you know that's what it's really all
about ian you want to tell me about your
beard feedback
i mean there's a gallery of some of the
replies i got
okay let's see what people thought it
was very sweet people been heckling ian
on social media year is it
i thought it was very nice to post a
picture of myself and my girlfriend you
know something kind of sentimental and
you're sharing well this right out the
gate they just said shave
so this is the photo by the way because
when you told me about this and then
when i went on instagram and saw the
photo myself i was like i see why people
are saying that
to be fair so
shave somebody's one of these messages
is ethan
man looking like you are like a [ __ ]
dude i didn't say that how dare you
he did message me though and he was like
i get why they
responded the way they did yeah
man looking like forrest gump when he
decided to stop running right never know
what you're going to get
ian i can't keep defending you get a
haircut
all right that's what i'm saying i don't
think you have to shave it just clean up
a little bit
no it's not it's all coming off the
whole point
is it's nasty someone said ian you good
[Laughter]
just concerned just blanket concern
i appreciate their concern
very robin williams from jumanji vibes
that's uh the robin williams jumanji
of comparison i mean i live in a jungle
room so i i appreciate that
oh what year is it
ian why does it seem you are homeless
and she found you under the pier
that's true that's a funny observation
isn't it
[Laughter]
caveman and a woman from civilization
meet and greet
people say you this is pretty funny it's
pretty funny random [ __ ]
a lot this is just like a small sample
amazing
yes i appreciate the flint army this
picture screams wilson
wow tom hanks from uh
castaway ladies and gentlemen well done
love that
ian's serving the industrial revolution
and its consequences
interesting that's pretty high level
what's the joke that you're like a
marxist yeah
yes you are kind of a marxist aren't you
ian so it's
maybe i i mean it's kind of accurate
i mean yeah me and carl have similar
fashion
at least in that regard unibomber
but he loves that about you
damn these [ __ ] are brutal
he's getting roasted and also these are
like private messages they're not even
doing it for other people they're just
doing it
to [ __ ] roast you 101. how did all
this make you feel ian
i mean it's it's funny i appreciate the
feedback
good feedback yeah it's good
constructivity
you look like a zoologist respectfully
yeah you remind me of charles manson in
this picture wow and that's just a dude
being like
hey just so you know because you weren't
aware
that's the vibe i'm getting can we put a
swastika on your forehead
oh that's all of them yeah that's it
some funny ass people
back there so are you going to
bow to peer pressure ian well i i
was planning on it anyway i was trying
to book a hair appointment
and then i posted this picture and i was
like oh man i never really
clarified why i have such a ratty
disgusting beard so
i had that coming i i was telling zach i
think there's like a small bird
living inside maybe
somewhere yeah
well we wish you all the best i'd love
to cut it for you we'll bring a barber
out do some tricks
do some like you know those barbers get
up some crazy [ __ ] these days maybe burn
it off you've seen those guys that like
burnt did the burning haircut oh my god
the guy with the axe somebody somebody
send that the burning haircut this is
what i want to get you ian
please let me do this
yo ian you have to let us do this
we'll have a safety supervisor i'll be
standing by with a virus
extinguisher to burn hair off my face no
these guys are professionals bro look at
this
they do it specifically in india for
some reason but there's no reason that
that shouldn't look at this [ __ ] bro
this is this could be you
they set your hair on fire and then cut
it why
no [ __ ] clue dude your hair's been on
fire for like a
long time why is he sitting there so
calm
your hair's smoking dog
what could be the purpose of that
uh to give it texture i suppose is the
only thing i could really
i mean after you ever cinched your hair
it's horrible the texture is horrible
the smell is the worst part
dog your hair is like on seriously on
fire right now
i guess it seals the ends and bonds them
together from what i'm reading right now
oh so if you have oh so there's actually
some kind of
well that's what the people who do it
say yeah with this kind of thing you got
to wonder
it makes me wonder why only in india if
it was that good it's not
it's not only in india yeah this
[ __ ] got a blog tour
a lot of the videos are from india
though i don't i i guess maybe it's
pocket i never seen anyone do again
outside of india
i have i i yeah i fall i actually
look at this guy look at his bro what
are you doing
what is this he's gonna oh this is oh no
this is india's still
bra that's just dry hair with a candle
oh no no no that can't be good for your
hair
that ain't that ain't that's not bonding
[ __ ] that's just burning your hair
fire yeah i'm seeing in italy california
oh ian please let us do this to you
please we can find somebody in kelp i'm
begging you
especially with a beard i'll do it with
you i need a haircut too
if let's do it together let's all get
let's all do it in
i don't have any hair to cut right out
i'll get a trim but i don't know if i
can get rid of the mane dude
here i got a beard one from love you
guys want to see a beard set on fire
i wouldn't want nothing more ian please
let me do this to you
ian please stand up here this guy's
setting his beard on fire
wet oh what
bruh what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] there's no way this is
doing anything
what is he doing oh he just like burned
his
what was that you guys there's no way
that did anything
i haven't got a [ __ ] clue it's
bizarre he just he moved it way too fast
okay here here's more here i want to see
if he actually lights him on fire
love you say he sets his [ __ ] on fire
no not not more than that i sent another
time stamp
where he does it on the other side and i
want to wash
his beard on fire i don't want these
little cute little zaps
[Laughter]
so i said look at this dude
yes look at this
ian that could be you
look at this so something tells me
though that you're not down for this or
are you kidding or just be straight with
me i mean because i'll bring a
professional out here and i'll do it
with you
why don't we just go grab a match in uh
candle lysol and let's just get it over
with in here
set you on fire
these guys are professionals these guys
they they act like they don't know what
the [ __ ] they're doing
i guarantee these guys are just putting
fire to the dome and praying for the
best every time
i'm reading some more about it i guess i
guess it's about burning off split ends
primarily that's [ __ ] uh fire
creates
look how vlog his head's on fire
he steals the moisture maybe he says it
seals
the moisture for for that dude needs a
little fire between his uh eyebrows you
know what i'm saying
peace and love i mean it's a vibe if
you're into it fire
okay there's no way that his head's not
like
there's no way that that's not immensely
painful right i mean he's got a flame on
his head for like
a fair amount of time
keep opening different websites about it
and every one of them seems to have a
different explanation of why people do
it which
kind of points me in the direction of
it being [ __ ] of course it's
vulnerable to get on the same page about
i mean i i don't know anything about
taking care of hair
so you know maybe dan's gonna be uh
maybe it was
grinding up a rhino horn and eating it
for
sexual prowess because now i'm looking
at okay this guy's beard actually gets
on fire apparently
with just a straight up lighter you guys
there's no fancy [ __ ] here this is
just a dude with a lighter
dan should mayo up that dome
yeah ian what do you think i mean we we
don't have to hire anyone for this
right come in a letter it's just a
lighter and a comb i mean
i could just go to the dollar store and
be ready
so can i do this to you then just me
doing it to you
uh i'll have to think about it i mean
then you want to go find like an
excavator and we'll do some
yeah right afterwards i'll put your ass
on an excavator toss your ass in the
ocean
oh this is so funny and
i mean you're welcome to do it
yeah i i'm down to do it i'll do it i'll
give a [ __ ]
look how nice it looks look how clean he
looked
it's awesome love me daddy
10 million views man people love
watching the [ __ ] here let's read the
comments
yes i would like number two on the side
and back on fire please
and back and top on fire
what do you want the barber customer you
know that guy ghost rider
fire just because you can do something
doesn't mean you should
very good comment
well let's try to find a barber to
specialize in this i'll do it if ian
won't
we'll do it's a perfect off the rail
segment it's like oh you lose here
ethan's head is on fire
ela's not here god's gonna have a flame
coming out of your butthole yeah
um yeah i guess if uh anybody out there
is in the greater los angeles area and
knows a barber that uh
does this technique reach out yeah or
just i mean we could do some research
tools probably
i'm sure that yeah i'm gonna i know one
of you guys on standby with a fire
extinguisher though
yes for sure
i'll even have them trim my eyebrows
with flame i don't give a [ __ ]
eyebrows that sounds terrifying
eyebrow you know i'm getting older my
eyebrows are starting to grow you've got
one random long eyebrow hairs that
happen
big time oh big time so i've always had
bushy ass
already trimmed with a flame what better
way
why stop there maybe he can do like my
body my ass
beautiful brazilian with a flamethrower
you know
get some third-degree burns and maybe
i'll get some time off too
sure medical leave for burning your
genitalia burn burn
okay listen we've got another huge
announcement here
and okay i'm somewhat conflicted on this
i i don't know how to okay well let's
just let's just say it straight
craft mail did the
what i think is unfortunately the
inevitable
i know they excluded zach
where's the initial tweet where they
show the finalists but
it is interesting they they sent you
this i wonder if they sent this to other
people or if they just trying to appease
you zack
what do you think well i finally they
sent it to the podcast twitter i never
received a
message on my personal page oh yeah but
we submitted it from the podcast how are
they supposed to be
okay yeah that's fair enough zach's
finding any reason to get pissed off now
they didn't hunt me down um
it's it's look
it is what it is but i'm not happy and
zack's down playing it he had a [ __ ]
meltdown when he found out about that we
have a video
it's really not an exaggeration well let
me read the message they messaged our
podcast twitter hey at the h3 podcast
thank you for submitting your entry to
become our next craft mayo
uh mayo dorsman we appreciate all the
time and dedication put into videos like
yours
they didn't say years by the way they
said we appreciate the time and
dedication put into videos
like yours not a direct compliment
no it's a total snub while your
submission did not become a top eight
finalist we are happy to recognize your
originality
personality and of course zach your
passion for craft mayo
yeah i am passion as an honorable
mention
this title will get you an exclusive
craft mayon endorsement t-shirt
did we provide our mailing info for that
no i mean i don't want to spoil it
because it's in the video but we we had
somewhat of a curt response let's see oh
no
we're the war has begun well this is
where it gets
interesting they say here's a free
t-shirt
and then they also offer a year's supply
of craft mail now i'm very curious what
does that mean
because they've seen how we use mayo and
we bathe in it so i'm wondering how far
can we stretch a year's supply of mayo
i mean it's such a [ __ ] you to us like
it's like oh here you go
here's a [ __ ] t-shirt you know
i mean it's literally a consolation
prize yeah [ __ ] them
to redeem your prize please let us know
the best address
to send it to thanks again for showing
up and showing off your love for mayo
yeah bastards
i kind of knew this was coming you know
maybe
maybe okay hear me out i know we're like
ruining their contest
and the thing is if you got in the top
eight you would definitely win by a
landslide right
so i'm wondering if they're just trying
to be fair about it
or i'll be honest with you zach maybe
they knew you weren't using real craft
mayo in the [ __ ] swimming pool it's
about time we come clean on that
why would you admit that what what what
what are you talking about
you already lost zach the gig is up the
jig is up
it's [ __ ] over dude you're not
winning [ __ ]
dan went and bought uh like yeah they
don't sell uh at costco gallons of uh
craft made maybe they know they're like
that's not craft mail you think i'd
bathe in their [ __ ]
product right you think i would let that
touch my [ __ ] skin
not real crap hellmann's you would use
right of course or maybe like nature's
or what is the
there's like that class one best
something fast food that is yeah best
foods is kind of the icon
i uh yeah and i i say in my rant that i
am a hellman's boy now and craft can go
[ __ ] themselves
rough well let's let's watch the video
because so here's zach's
genuine reaction i don't think he's
playing this up
when the hammer came down it was big
news when they tweeted out the finalists
and we're like zach's not there
i [ __ ] called it i knew they weren't
going to include you
they've been snubbing you all month well
they sent the dm before they put out the
um
the finalists well they're clearly
scared of the mayo war that's brewing
they know what's coming
i'm just confused because it's like on
one hand they want the publicity right
which we gave them out the [ __ ]
wad zoo we're like the only
our audience is the only people paying
attention to this like who the [ __ ]
cares about craft mail
social media no one when have any of you
guys
ever out there interacted with a
mayonnaise social media website
and by the way to what end who gives a
[ __ ] i
i had a bit of a conspiracy that the
bar stool connection i found interesting
yeah we we've got to talk about the
barstool connection
okay let's watch zach's reaction and
then we can talk about the bar stool
conspiracy
but okay are the finalists a bar stool
associated ian
no i mean we'll we'll watch the video
okay here here's zach's
uh unfettered
response today what's going on i missed
it it's the podcast square
what the [ __ ] we just found out hey free
podcast thank you for submitting your
entry
to become our next come on already
endorsement
we appreciate all the time and
dedication put into videos like first
nice music
your submission did not become a top
eight finalist
we are happy to recognize the
originality zach spent that money
oh really for craftsmen yeah i am back
as an honorable mention this title
will get you an exclusive hashtag craft
mayo endorsement t-shirt
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you hey and
your supply of craft mail hey
your supply [ __ ] you crap my voice cry
nice [ __ ] you and now i gotta keep it in
god damn it all right
for showing up and showing off your love
for mayo sincerely
team real craft mail hey team real crap
now
right there right there [ __ ] okay and
i'm true
i'm admitting this right now and this is
true
show my phone i love dan's response
dan just writes you just made the
biggest
mistakes of your lives
a threat on a holiday [ __ ] you craft
mayonnaise
he let them know he literally cracked me
he let me know
[ __ ] you crap i said you just made the
biggest mistake yeah
all right is there so i think we got is
there should i keep watching
they would maybe uh kind of calm me down
he walked you off well that's not funny
i mean i think they just wanted it to be
fair but you guys so ian what's your
conspiracy ian knows something
interesting about the bar stool
well i just noticed when i was going
through the um
i kept getting craft advertisements
because i'm on this mail page all the
time now
and all of that so sorry i got to
interrupt you
who's going out and buying mayonnaise
because they got a sponsored spot
no one what is the mayonnaise is
mayonnaise business rough for craft mail
i mean what is this whole thing even
about bro it's in the grocery store i'll
buy
mayonnaise when i need it right anyway
sorry
i was just saying i i kept getting these
ads and they were all from
bar stool promoting this competition and
when i went in the hashtag
i saw like every single promoted tweet
was from like a bar stool affiliate
there's no such thing as a coincidence
what
wait who so wait craft was paying to
promote bar stool
man yeah it was like barstool sports
sign up now to do the craft may
endorsement
and then it said promoted by real craft
mayo so
there's no such thing as a coincidence
we got a little bit of barstool beef
over here on the show wait here's zach
oh that's someone's a photoshop
okay i'm looking to the
i'm trying to find the
look at the engage the thing is is that
craft
is a craft mayonnaise specifically is a
big sponsor
of barstool sports if you google
barstool
uh craft mail there's all kinds of
videos where
it's like this section brought to you by
craft mayo do you love mayo
wake up so that there's there's some
deep ties there's some real
yo here's the main barstool sports
twitter account
the finalists for craft mail have been
announced what
why oh so this was never meant for us
dave rigged
this was some bar stool [ __ ] that we
got involved in and they rigged the
[ __ ] election yep
there's casey john what's going on
they're stealing that time of the year
the time
everyone's been wondering when it's
coming it's here now it's craft mail
endorsement time
we've limited it down to eight different
candidates for who's gonna be
oh my god you know what's ironic we
ended up sending them a million times
more
traffic than [ __ ] they're paying
barstool for this whole dumbass thing
and we're here actually doing the
legwork and they can't even pick our boy
he's stealing that no it's a total
[ __ ]
fraud [ __ ] election yeah holy
[ __ ] yep yep yep
yeah whoa i bet dave pork by might have
even had something to do with it because
we have beef i
would [ __ ] him bet my [ __ ] life on it
i want the [ __ ] billboard man zach
so okay hang on we have okay i gotta see
more
dig deeper into this bar stool dude
you're getting sponsored posts from
barstool about the craft mayo's
competition that is odd to me yup
i can't do that i literally can't
their post has 40 likes you guys this is
not
acceptable
oh man
okay you know i was on the fence like
maybe they just wanted to be fair
you know maybe they just want a proper
winner and
and zac but but no i'm this is [ __ ]
war
bro yep okay let's make it clear
i just want to make it clear because i
already saw some people
on the subreddit and stuff uh
complaining about this this isn't about
the other contestants leave the other
content oh i'm not even showing them by
the way
the other entries were good i mean right
i just want to make this clear to our
audience
do not go after the other no no no no no
no no no we lost with them we love them
and good they get the money yeah that's
fine they get the clout they get the
billboard outside barstool headquarters
oh and by the way don't be surprised if
one of the winners is a bar stool
employee
yeah they're going to get their own
podcast for the [ __ ]
so congratulations to the winners this
beef is with wheelcraft mayo and now
apparently bar stool
dave pork boy you know what's good on uh
i feel like the unfortunate anti-semitic
because he's like jewish
what you know because we call him pork
boy because i was like you know what
looks good on por goes good on pork
mayonnaise how is it anti-semitic if
he's jewish
because jews aren't supposed to eat pork
i know but that so
just i mean listen i
just don't follow him because we call
him pork boy i get that
i just don't really see how it's
anti-semitic
well don't people do that for arabs
where they say like oh pork
i've heard people use that as an insult
for like members of the muslim faith
inappropriate yeah like school humor i
guess sometimes like
want some of this pepperoni pizza yeah i
mean that's the thing is like
if you're like teasing somebody and like
or like tricking them into eating
some pork or something that's obviously
[ __ ] up but just calling him pour
what's he love wiggling about over there
that's my co-pilot you guys see love
over dan's shoulder yeah
how are you doing love you okay yeah i'm
doing great
you feel comfortable inside the uh bot
yep
i'm just looking over down here making
sure he's doing everything how's he
doing everything i know you look like a
supervisor he's doing great
he's doing great thanks man excellent
thanks man he's like my chewy
to my hand yeah we need that i i wish i
had more of a presentation on the bar
stool involvement
well i mean there's not
there's not a lot of solid evidence
it's gonna take some more digging but i
mean
there's obviously a connection barstool
sports is sponsored by craft mayo
they've been promoting the contest and
anybody that knows their h3 history
knows that
dave portboy's got a he's got a problem
with ethan
portnoy [ __ ] me he [ __ ] us so
[ __ ] him i'm writing along
are you are you writing a response yeah
okay
good we're waiting into this it's
getting real okay here's what i wrote
stream of consciences this is where
y'all [ __ ] up this is a deep
conspiracy to steal it from barstool
we know what is going on we can read
between the lines you're stealing it
it's so obvious
you'll regret this and corruption on
this level cannot stand i'm going to the
white house i'm writing my senator
there we go respond
i appreciate that ethan thank you i'm
not done
i'm not done this is a war
this is a war between good and evil
evil corruption and underhanded dealing
must be eradicated from this earth
we represent the will of the people
we are born with uh unalienable
rights and you are stomping
on them this is just
the beginning say hi to dave
pork boy for me
[Music]
done and that is a threat wow
dave pork boy
yeah i was kind of with the guy i was
because i saw people being like maybe we
should
let the other people have their fun with
it yeah and not ruin it
i okay they had their fun they got their
winner
now it's time for [ __ ] war
that's it's such [ __ ] and we've done
hundreds of thousands of dollars of
promotion for craft [ __ ] mayonnaise
the least they could do is hook up my
boy zach and they send us a [ __ ]
t-shirt
like that's such a [ __ ] you right
we should fill out the and get the prize
though because i want to i think
that ship may have sailed at this point
let's see
should i respond right now just have to
respond and say
okay by the way we will take the team
well yeah i mean you're entitled they
what are they going to renege on their
offer
i mean after talking [ __ ] and that's a
lawsuit bro
you know i really got to thank the uh
the foot soldiers for their support
you know after you know i didn't get in
the top eight
uh just gotta thank them and thank
everybody for the support
um but yeah it's [ __ ] well let's see
what happens with the billboard
i have pledged to get you a billboard
opposite of the winners
hellman hellman sponsoring helmets we
should reach out to helmets maybe they
want to work with us
i would not be like uh you're kind of a
[ __ ] issue dude
we don't want you turning on us
um we'll make this right zach thank you
but i'm very curious about what a
lifetime supply of mayonnaise looks like
so
all right i i dm them i said and by the
way you can send it to
our address thank you so much god bless
dude they're gonna they're gonna come
like
commit warfare on us hit fast fit first
they're gonna send a hit man after us
the art of war dude hit first
good offense is a good defense maybe
they'll think it's a trap i sent this uh
address there's gonna be an ambush well
didn't they say to click and fill out a
form
yeah that was on there oh okay yeah oh
you just giving out our address to the
mail guy
[ __ ] their form [ __ ] their form no i
want the prize
okay fine i want to know what lifetime
supply mayo looks no it's a year supply
of mayonnaise
oh yeah a year which is just another
chicken [ __ ] [ __ ] you to us
but you know you know they this
no one can compete to what we did i did
there were some good entries zach let's
be honest well no there was and
you deserve to be in the top eight
though the the dude that
um he should win there's one guy that
should win i believe his name is
nicholas
so please vote for him um
but yeah it's [ __ ] nicholas your boy
no it's not my boy if someone was gonna
split the money with him no
if someone was gonna win i hope it's him
all right well here's what i got planned
next
uh let's go test ride the gatsby
versus the love robot we've built a
little bit of an obstacle course out
there
these guys are so worried i don't know
you guys are so worried i'm gonna hurt
myself it's not that crazy
i'm really worried you're really worried
yeah yeah
you all are really worried dude the
gatsby is not a toy
it weighs like 2 000 pounds it goes like
25 miles an hour you can i can't get it
over your love is still turning while
you're talking to face you
you're not planning on wearing a helmet
or any protective gear i mean this is
you guys
this isn't exactly they're tiny they're
so i know but
it's just a shitty piece of plywood it's
going to snap under the weight of the
gatsby
there's there's all right well i'm not
saying
it's not a guarantee that you're going
to get hurt but it's let's not pretend
it's not within
well you know what's the difference
between me and david i would never put
you guys
in that position yeah i mean you're
doing it you can do whatever you want i
would never
ask ian for example to light his head on
fire
right never but i would oh yeah but no i
wouldn't i wouldn't have you guys drive
it that'd be crazy if i thought there
was a real risk
it's me i am a selfless leader a heroic
leader really right i put myself on the
line
uh for this show for the entertainment
and if ela was here she would definitely
stop me from doing this
that's why it's off the rails
can i get an amen amen who runs just
remember if i get injured you all
kind of out of work interestingly
yep yeah that's why i don't want you to
do this what do you think
why do you think that's the only reason
dan no that's not the only thing
i just don't want to see you hurt but
also yeah obviously that would suck
financially as well you see the ramps
they're tiny i don't know you guys are
tripping balls
love is right up on you huh i just
noticed it says
[ __ ] craft mayo on his uh robot oh you
can put a little
yeah you can write a message thank you
thank you for the support
yeah of course the line break did come
uh yeah so it actually says [ __ ] craft
may like the month of may and then the
letter o
very slick that's some slick technology
by the way we spent four thousand
dollars on that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
about the same price as the gatsby so we
have equal
technology cost right yeah i hadn't
considered that
i i don't think that this thing is going
to be able to keep pace with the gatsby
though
unfortunately it's interesting um
we we waste i wouldn't say waste but we
threw down a lot of money for the gag in
the gatsby
we threw down equally amount for this
love bot which doesn't look like much
but
i mean he is controlling it from sweden
right now that is pretty awesome
yeah that is pretty amazing let's that's
true
all right well let's go let's go put
them to the test let's go one on one
let's see what's up let's see
let's see who's going who wins
you got your robot talking all right
let's see what happens i'm just going to
give you a little tap let's do a chicken
here come right here
okay let's see i'm just going to give
you a little tap
oop
interesting dude kind of the bottom wins
that round
instead it's grown good
it's pretty resilient all right let's
have one chicken fight
chase and don't even
[Laughter]
bro
yes dude look at the power of the gatsby
bro
it's my office i own this place what are
you guys worried about
he's just trying to prove a point now
yeah all right let's get to the
competition
all right let's hit it hit it as hard as
you can bro
full speed it's full speed
[Music]
don't give up bro you're right there i'm
trying just
give it a little kick yeah just give me
a big key there it is there it is
another one
there you go yeah this thing is good man
now take out the box
[Applause]
nice
look at that all right
my turn
all right
[Music]
um
oh
all right let's check in with love and
see who won that round
let's just chicken all right
what do we think how'd we do bot versus
catchment
you killed that first ramp though so i'm
not even going to hate on you for that
yeah i didn't clear the ramp but i mean
the speed isn't there
and the aggression the aggression is not
there
no not at all i'm surprised if they
would even allow this in public settings
like this thing could literally kill
someone
get a shot at dan look at him we already
knew what this thing could do because we
all right well we did it all right you
want to erase my boosted board
oh yeah it'll be fine put me between
your legs put the
wheels on the thing come here
here this is like this is like a make a
wish
like you want to know what it feels go
[Laughter]
[Music]
faster
and everything
[Music]
look at this i can't
oh that's balance fast bro where's she
gonna win
i'm not doing anything
what the [ __ ]
okay three two
one
[Applause]
yeah you got me butt wow i was on low
that whole time bro
this thing is uncontrollable and hot
[Laughter]
[Music]
bro loves a robot's probably dizzy you
put it on the floor
okay hit that thing are we doing chicken
you want to do chicken we gotta set you
guys further apart no get over here
no three two one
love gets a head start
it's still up how you feel love oh
you just got knocked the [ __ ] out just
put me back on my teeth
oh [ __ ]
run left run that thing
you guys is it it has a little bumper
around it
let's ride together in harmony
oh [ __ ] the we got we lost some
straighten that yeah me and my body love
we've been through a lot today
it's been a hell of a day
you know it's just been a good
fun competition here so
we're going in a day here and it's been
good fun times
all right i gotta say that gatsby should
not be
that fast the fact that you can flip it
over
it's a literally a mobility scooter that
you can
flip over because it's so powerful and
fast
that thing should not even be allowed in
public settings
the thing is when i hit that ramp i was
on slow i didn't realize
and when i ripped it into high gear i
almost flip i almost flipped over
because the
it's kind of sticky and it gets stuck on
the accelerator and there's not a
let's be clear there's no break on the
[ __ ] gatsby
it's a disability you just kind of flip
it in reverse and hope it slows down but
i'm not even convinced it does anything
at all
and um yeah i just googled it again
and on its spec listing it says top
speed 10 miles per hour
bro no way yeah yo we got to get a
speedometer let's get a speedometer
like a radar gun yeah you can do it on
snapchat let's do it right now
you can do it on snapchat yeah remember
i was telling you guys that person got
an accident because they were trying to
go fast is that accurate i mean yeah
because my boosted board only goes up to
20 miles an hour
let's do it right now real quick okay
all right hold on we're going to do a
speed test
oh my god okay we tried the speed test
it didn't work i think it was going too
fast probably for it to compute
but we did buy the radar gun right dan
i i just purchased the radar gun okay so
we've got the radar gun
more gatsby content to come
but um god i forgot how fast that thing
whips bro
crazy that's how i roll i have one speed
i have one gear
genuinely worried for your safety yeah
dan wasn't he was like i'm not
participating
and went in the corner and pretend like
he didn't see
we love dan but that thing should not
that thing's not street legal you could
kill someone in that and i'm not joking
if i took that to disney i could
probably take out a whole crowd of
people
i could do like a straight [ __ ]
mini 911 on the catchphrase
yeah you know yeah that's not safe well
we love that about it
all right coming up here we've got this
segment we've been working on
we're talk we're calling it the inc we
were planning on doing this angry
thursday but we thought we'll just do it
a segment here so this is
angry thursday on wednesday
[Music]
the angry round talk every one of the
gang here
and myself has brought in a topic
that has made them angry irritated
annoyed something that's cause just
grinding their
we gears going to go one at a time what
is going on in your lives
that is upsetting you let's [ __ ] get
angry boys dance is the gatsby probably
dan you want to go first
you're right it is the gatsby really
uh well you just prepared this right now
you were supposed to prepare this like i
know and the truth is so
i had a hard time with this and
this may come as a surprise to some
people because i have a reputation on
the show i'm well aware that i'm dan the
hater
and yeah dan the hater for a reason for
a reason
but the truth is like i
even if i hate on something i i'm i'm
i'm actually a pretty detached person
i don't actually get really mad about
anything like
it's bluster you know what i mean it's
just bluster so when i was
i really was thinking about it hard last
night i'm like what in my life
am i like getting mad at it all the time
and um
and really kind of came up empty-handed
but then
we were just shooting that segment and
you slamming
into the walls destroying the drywall
slamming into the tables that we spent
all last week setting up
oh please it took five seconds to salute
him back
and i was i was i was getting a little
mad i was getting a little mad but um
so i mean i know that that's kind of
lackluster but don't worry um
our boy ab over here uh he's chomping at
the bit he told me he had a list of like
20 items
okay well hold on dan let's not move
along so fast i mean
what first of all we got the gatsby i
spent four thousand dollars on that
thing because it's funny
we've got this huge office and open
space and then i wipe it out and start
having a good time you start pouting in
the corner like
i mean why can't i just have why do you
have to go away and be like
because it's not well one because
i feel like there was a decent chance of
of serious physical harm was somebody
harmed
no no no and and i'm very grateful for
that you dan
no no thanks to you because you just
came in satin and
let everyone else do it it is actually
somewhat thanks to me because i have a
confession you know how you discovered
that it was on the low setting
whatever i checked that was my fault oh
i
i went and flipped it to low right
before you hi you didn't honestly
okay i didn't i didn't okay because i
was like why was it on low
i didn't want to say anything but i
remember putting it too high i'm like
that's weird
no i put it on high too you went when
when did you do that i was on the guess
for the whole time when i was
no uh because i i lined it up for you
before we got started
interesting and also because i was on it
and like
you know i think it's dangerous man
you were just explaining how you could
murder somebody with it that's what's
funny about it dan
it's funny until you until you tip it
over while you're
drifting on it and it falls on you this
is off the rails i don't need another
girl
right here you're going to tom segura
you're put you're trying to keep me on
the rails dan
somebody has to somebody has to
all right dan so so yours is the gatsby
i i don't know if i want to put it on
the gatsby sounds like it's me
i mean can i can i dig a little deeper
is it more that you get angry that you
try to keep the show on rails sometimes
and you kind of get [ __ ] for it
uh try to keep us all again again angry
is a strong word i don't know i'm
i'm oh stop it dan i've seen you get mad
yeah what do i usually get mad about
do you get mad well we got in a fight
for what yeah
what because of me and that was the
implication we got in a pretty
bad fight once when with the vape
remember the vape the vape
it was a long time ago we had the giant
vape when we were doing shooting the
video oh well i mean yeah that was just
it was a stressful day yeah it was a
stressful day but you got you were
getting pretty upset
yeah i mean i would say early on to us
working together
are we we did get into it a decent
amount
you know we had to kind of we kind of
had to find the equilibrium yeah we used
to butt heads a little bit yeah but um
i feel like it's actually really good
now well yeah we were shooting the the
vape nation
ii video and that giant vape and at the
time at the time it was just me i mean i
don't think even yeah was working for me
no it's just you so it's just me
yeah and we were shooting all day it was
a really [ __ ] hot day that vape is
like
400 pounds well i was in a full gucci
tracksuit so i was like right and there
were and there were some technical
problems happening with it
and like it was just it was just rough
it was it was a rough shoot
but so we we get out to we're start on
hollywood
right and i put on this thing it was
pretty it's super [ __ ] heavy and i
didn't expect that so first of all i'm
like dude how are we gonna shoot this
video
and we had like a big sponsorship lined
up so like right there there was
no option there we were shooting this
video so i had this giant
[ __ ] vape that probably weighed 70
pounds legitimately
on the oh i think it's more i think it's
more yeah i think it's more than 70.
i i it's probably about 100 pounds so
i'm
literally 100 pounds here and the strap
it has
a vest it breaks the minute i put it up
like immediately
and so i was like damn didn't you guys
test this and then you're like well why
don't you come down and do the fitting
because and i was like well what does it
matter if i do the fitting the the
straps don't matter if it's me or you or
anyone else trying it on
right i mean i had tried i had tried it
on there but obviously
it they kind of dropped the ball and
those straps yeah and they put in some
really weak straps for 100 pound gadget
yes and they broke literally immediately
yeah
so we ended up going running to the
store and getting like i got a bunch of
zip ties and we
we we did a makeshift i mean it all
worked out and that video came out great
so
i agree it was but yeah it was just i'm
just saying i've seen you angry
that's true you're about to have a
meltdown that day to be totally honest
uh
yeah well again it was there was a lot
of factors going into that yeah yeah but
i don't blame you but um
i'm just saying i i agree so you're
right i i mean i
i certainly do get angry but that's the
thing when i was just sitting thinking
about like what in my life like really
gets me mad
like i just don't like i
i'm more of a whiner i'll whine about
things but i'm not actually mad it's
kind of like halloween you don't have to
get well
okay how about this how about the
insulin prices
i know that bothers you yeah yeah that's
a good one that
that is that is very upsetting yeah yeah
i mean like there's just political stuff
but what am i gonna do
you get on soapbox you start ranting
yeah politics i mean well you're not a
diabetic dancer all right so
dan hates me what so i care about
insulin prices just because i'm not
diabetic
is that what you're saying
uh well so in summary dan hates me
i know it's not true that's not true all
right you try
what's bothering you and i mean i was
just going to say one but i mean yeah i
made like a list no problem yeah let's
start with one and see
okay dude
let me begin uh i hate when people post
on like reddit or
on like uh youtube comments or my own
comments why does ab follow this person
why does a b follow keem i seen a uav a
comment
just the other week because it's my job
i'm i got to keep up with whoever we're
talking about there's a lot of people
i follow that i don't like so yeah i've
been wondering why you follow bill cosby
for example and you follow o.j simpson
you follow the woody allen i was like oh
yeah you followed oj yeah he had him
blocked you oh right he blocked me yeah
you guys walked by
the world this is yours truly because i
kept commenting under all this post like
i don't remember something about him you
know just something about him being a
murderer
yeah just like those though good slice
there oj i haven't seen a slice that
good since your trial in 90 or whatever
yeah
stuff like that i convinced lena once
i kind of told dan this story i wasn't
sure if i wanted to tell on air but i
kind of convinced her that
oj was threatening your life for real
and like yeah like he found out like
wait i don't think you've told me this
maybe it was zack or something i don't
know i kind of loosely mentioned it to
you so
yeah one time over break you know i
don't drink i don't do anything so i'm
kind of just very boring but i uh
i don't know i want to live the cali
life i guess and i tried like a little
edible
and uh i don't think lena knew it was
and lena
wait you dosed her without her knowledge
i smoke weed
every day i am maybe no i mean like well
she
i don't know i kind of don't want to get
her in too much trouble let me let me
just say let me say that okay
she didn't know she didn't know she
didn't know right because she would
never do that
yeah and she would never do that this is
the this is when i found out that i'm
really kind of an [ __ ] because
for whatever reason you don't mind you i
was like tripping out because i never do
anything
i thought it was funny to pretend that
like oj was like threatening us that's
so [ __ ] because
there was such an [ __ ] and i was like
i was like you can't tell anyone you
know ethan just told me that
i don't i don't know i don't know where
it came from i'm like listen
we have to be careful we just did a
conference call and said like he knows
you know
he's going to find out where all of us
are where we're living and i'm like but
you can't
tell anyone and lena's like wait are you
serious i'm like yeah and then
i even pretended dan called me and i'm
like i'm like oh [ __ ] hold on that's
dude
yeah i'm like i'm like oh i was holding
my phone yeah i was like
i was like did you say anything or she
was like no i swear i didn't say
anything
you really are a sinner it was just you
and lena
and you when she was high
that personality test was right dude
that's on my list too zach actually
you know what can i add something to my
rageless yeah people that [ __ ] with
people when they're high
you guys have no idea because i know i
was so evil i don't smoke weed anymore i
don't like the effect of being high
but when i was younger i had like this
[ __ ] group of friends who would
always [ __ ] with you when you're high
and it's just it's not cool it's like
yeah it's like it just kills the vibe so
hard so shout out to a b
you know i i hate those people too so
let me get this straight you dosed her
and then
convinced her that oj was coming to kill
her what kind of torture ass [ __ ] is
this
you are a [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't dose
her i just saw i
i don't want to get her in trouble yeah
yeah you
winked wink doster yeah dose my wife and
yeah sweetest person on earth
i don't know i don't know what that says
about me this was supposed to be about
you being mad about stuff but now
everyone's just mad at you yeah now
how did this turn to this what was i
complaining about i don't know i don't
know but everyone's everyone's rage is a
b
again oh bro
so what happened when you guys got sober
did you apologize did you come clean
what happened
she thought it was it was real she
thought it was she goes did i did i
write something did i message someone
about
oj coming after you guys i yeah
it was really funny okay but then when
was she mad when did you tell her that
it wasn't really good to her or did she
to this day think that that happened
she kept finding out watching this
episode right now hey twitter will you
guys
know the michael jackson poster that ian
got me for the christmas episode yeah
it was like hanging up and she's like
what did what did i say and i was like
looking at the picture i'm like don't
tell her anything don't tell her and
she's like
like she was like fully convinced that
like she was like tripping that much
that she thought i was talking to
a poster on the wall oh yeah maybe
yeah would you did you ever break it to
her that oh yeah yeah yeah i thought so
when did that happen when you got
covered up or immediately
uh when i was writing this segment when
i no i'm playing i told her i told her
like right after
you told her when you guys sobered up
right now yeah okay
yeah i she called me a buzzkill but she
said it distracted her
but i definitely have a buzzkill oh yeah
which is definitely i never
thought i'll play dude that is a foul
play yeah
we swore off ever do anything again now
that was the last time
oh so she had a really bad experience if
they're like we're never doing anything
like that one and done baby damn
don't smoke weed with a b yeah i'm
serious
i guess so dude i'm still thinking back
to i think back to that moment a lot
you feel bad about it yeah because i
feel like i'm really passive and i'm
really
kind of chill i don't know do you blame
it on the weed or
chill dude you have like a whole legal
path full of things that
enrage you oh can you be well so hold on
what so
what do you how do you rationalize why
that happened do you think it was the
weed or
you're just do you really torture
yourself over this moment
i i just i like to always like over
cycle analyze everything i'm like why
my wife is the sweetest person on earth
did i try to convince her that oj
simpson was trying to kill me and my
co-workers
i mean and i sold it i sold that [ __ ]
you're good yeah i feel like you
i feel like that is potentially funny
but you just took it way too far
oh yeah definitely you know like that's
like if you want to [ __ ] with somebody
for like a second
and be like oh no i'm just playing but
it sounds like you you let this play out
oh yeah no i'm [ __ ] in the head i
don't know i i i'm not trying to be
funny right now i really feel bad
you're a good actor unless you feel bad
we need dr drew back to unpack that but
for real i have a
if you're listening to this and you are
someone that smokes weed with people i
have a strict
no [ __ ] with people while on drugs
policy
no [ __ ] with people on drugs amen i
support that fully
i smoke marijuana so i don't beat my
wife and children
what the [ __ ] was that baby's the
opposite of that
all right well that quickly turned into
a raging against abc's yeah
but that was interesting that was a good
story i mean we knew we knew this was
this was going to take us places like
hey lovebot do you have a story for us
um well to be honest i don't really hate
a lot of stuff
oh come on we don't need the disclaimer
just tell me what what's grinding your
gears
i know you're one thing that you're not
annoying me
is mcdonald's
no yeah i'm gonna drop it on mcdonald's
right now
okay um well in united states you know
mcdonald's
uh during kobe has been like really
strict they've had masks and stuff on
all their employees
and everything you know right typical
coveted guidelines yeah
but in sweden they don't really care
about
anything like that they don't really
wear ma don't they don't wear masks
no one wears masks no gloves no sanitary
stuff
because you know the kitchen is often
open so when you stand there and wait
for your food you just see how they
handle the food
and no gloves nothing at all right now
that's gonna take off well so is that is
that exclusive to mcdonald's
or is that just a wider thing in sweden
well i mean
covet result or kobe this stuff has been
pretty bad in sweden
uh almost united states levels but on a
lower
smaller scale right sure so in my
opinion the same
stuff should apply but are some
restaurants taking more precaution than
mcdonald's
yeah oh that's interesting you'd think
that the big corporate mcdonald's
wouldn't be taking any risks especially
when they say that they will in the
united states
that just goes to show that these
corporations put on the show like they
give a [ __ ] about you
but they're doing the least amount
minimum required by the law
because in sweden they're like oh no
there's no law that says we have to do
this so [ __ ]
everybody covet for everybody they're
not willing to spend a single cent to
make that [ __ ] safer
yeah i actually have a beef against
mcdonald's too you know
or also having to do with covid once
covid hit
they stopped serving breakfast at any
hour of the day oh yeah that is and that
has
[ __ ] my family life up more than you
can imagine
ila one of the only things i could go
drive through with with ela that she
would be happy about
was the egg mcmuffins and since that's
been gone
it's just i haven't had an egg mcmuffin
in a year because it's like all the time
what it's like
crack a [ __ ] egg i mean i don't get
that whole breakfast thing crack a
[ __ ] egg dude
what's the big deal it's so good i mean
they had fixed that because that was the
thing at mcdonald's for years
and then i don't know when it was but
yeah in the recent past they were
finally
like okay well we'll serve this all day
yeah what does covet have to do with
like not being able to do that anymore
you know they were back in the stone
ages yeah
excellent story love thank you so did
you stop going to mcdonald's or you
still go there and you just
you you roll the dice i i still eat
there yeah to be honest what do you like
there
chicken tasty it's called chicken
chicken chicken
is that a swedish thing what the hell's
this chicken taste yeah that's another
thing that i don't really like
they don't they have the shittiest menu
ever
because you know you on the internet you
might see like an ad for something new
on mcdonald's
and then you just realize it's only for
the united states
and the menu is always the same in
sweden it never changes pretty much so
what does a chicken is
tasty or yummy fried chicken tasty she
can taste it i don't know it's like a
burger it's like a yeah
and i i go with no cheese oh
there's the hey we got a love order
better get that collab going the chicken
tasty with no cheese
oh yeah boy all righty who wants to go
up next
uh zach yeah i know what yours is zach
well actually i'm gonna throw you a
little curveball okay
um what i mean one would be the mayo
thing but you know we
we talked about we covered that yeah
yeah um i have a bone to pick with
iphones and apple google actually
and i know this is going to make dan
happy because he he's not a uh
iphone fan if you will uh
what uh you said apple and google apple
google
and iphone i guess on this you have a
problem with all iphones
all smartphones here here's the okay and
i know ab can attest to this because
this has happened to him before
when you plug your phone in the car it
even if you turn wi-fi off you plug it
in
and you're trying to open your phone yes
mind are you driving
it this [ __ ] pop-up of can't sing
google contacts
can't sing google contacts always comes
[ __ ] up
don't have that problem you don't have
that problem never wow
i was ready to very specific i was ready
to defend
apple because i'm like a big apple fan
but i'm i know exactly what zack's
talking about
such i've for some reason it's some like
this past year or so there's some kind
of google can't uh
sync with servers error message yeah
it's the most frustrating
[ __ ] thing ever yeah i don't have
that problem
my my iphone i have this problem where
it happens in every car no matter what
phone i have
but it's like maybe it's because i share
cards with elan sometimes she drives
but it's like the bluetooth always gets
disconnected
for no [ __ ] reason and i always have
to go back to this
media screen connect the phone it's like
can you guys figure this [ __ ] out
right right no i hear you i've had that
issue it's also like step up the tech
like they can only connect to one
bluetooth
item at a time i've got a like a like a
you know a cordless uh speaker that
that we've been using for years that can
connect to two blue phone
bluetooth devices at the same time right
so it doesn't disconnect you all the
time
right right do you know what i'm saying
dan you're looking at me like you don't
uh i don't no i know what you're saying
i'm just
and it just doesn't seem like that big a
deal to me
oh my god it's so annoying you start
driving and then your the music doesn't
work
doesn't bother you i keep bluetooth off
because of that when i go in my car you
do what i keep bluetooth off on my
iphone whenever i'm in the car like
i don't want to jam to your tunes do you
want the other apple carplay yeah i plug
in
okay yeah see i have that too so i don't
have to deal with that do you have apple
carplay
either i do and it doesn't [ __ ] work
how does it all work it just doesn't
work bro
in the rolls yeah it doesn't work half a
million dollar car you can't [ __ ]
listen to music not a million but yeah
like
well i just do it on my bluetooth or
whatever it was
yeah well okay it doesn't work it just
doesn't connect anyways
this google [ __ ] function sucks needs
to be taken care of
it's [ __ ] okay top comment is going
to be somebody like
oh you just have to flip the switch in
this one thing you know i'm changing i'm
hating on dan right now
that's what my second eye is go on i
love this one damn being a [ __ ] knife
in the neck right now no see this is
this what i was talking about dan's
trying to
look out and he gets [ __ ] for it he's
trying to just give us a heads well he
presents it in such a
uh he minimizes that yeah he's
patronizing
minimizing your trauma minimizing your
trauma yeah you're minimizing his grades
patronizing you but he was i think
you're softening the blow the first time
no he was minimizing
yeah yeah dan the hater
thank you zach thank you zach maybe if
you guys gave him some love his heart
would open like the grinch
i give dan love so much love he does i'm
kidding he does
ian and ian stand up yeah ian please
stand up
please stand up thank you
[Applause]
all right ian what's bothering you yeah
i'm curious
uh i told this to zach and he said this
would be a good one i don't really know
who my rage is directed at
here or how i really feel i haven't
fully processed it i guess in the
emotions but
um i got some food the other day
and you know i love
all shout out to all the food workers i
have no beef no beef i don't want any
smoke
you say that like trump i ordered
something and it took him like 20
minutes to
get together and they brought it out and
they brought me the wrong thing
and it's fine it's whatever i just told
him i was like oh i actually ordered
this this isn't the right
and the woman gave me like the dirtiest
look the entire remaining time that i
was there
like she was just she's continued to
stare you down
yeah like like i was being a difficult
customer so
like she was glaring at me when i told
her she like snatched the bag back she
was very like
oh yeah i'm sure that yeah like she was
convinced that i
ordered the wrong thing this was now
whatever like you know [ __ ] happens i've
worked in food i understand
but uh
i had this i always have this fear
whenever that happens that now my food
is going to have like
spit or like someone's load
everyone's loved you know that [ __ ] does
happen i know it's crazy
it's hard to think about but that does
happen well yeah and
when i was younger when i was like in
middle school i had this friend of mine
and his older brother once told me a
story he was like yeah i used to know
this guy at domino's and
you just like bust fat nuts no tomato
sauce dude
people like something no no no no no
and i've never forgotten that and every
time something happens i'm like
there's some [ __ ] night
no do you think they they were lying i
hope they're lying
who busts a nut in the marinara well and
i brought this
up dan's worked in food and he had
stories
that he's seen you've seen someone bust
a nut in the mirror no no no no never
bust a nut
not saying that i'm saying that that
doesn't happen but no
but fortunately i never uh what's your
anecdote
uh well i mean i i worked as a waiter
for over
five years um and in that time
i will say i mean this is it's not
super common like in five years of
working there i probably
saw my co workers [ __ ] with food
a grand total of maybe seven or eight
times
over over the course of five years so
that's a lot bro that's weight i would
yeah well i mean it does happen so what
were they doing with the food
i mean i said the one that i told these
guys the other day that
that they all flipped out about is uh i
knew this girl
who if the customer if she really hated
a customer
she would uh take loose change and like
stir it around in their drinks
no yeah oh you just like take a
f that's the stuff that's that's
honestly criminal i mean
well i think it's all criminal that's
like [ __ ] more fair right i think
[ __ ] with food in any way like that
would
that's just not cool you have to be kind
of [ __ ] up to think that's okay to do
even if you're mad
she was pretty [ __ ] up she was not a
not a nice person
so yeah but sometimes not nice people
work in food service and so
of course i mean yeah everyone needs to
work unfortunately even the douche bags
yup exactly but um i i
i never knew anybody that just did it
sadistically
for the sake of it yeah but when you got
people like ian who are lying about
their orders then you get nothing like
that
yeah just oh man yeah
yeah unfortunately i've heard about that
from people too like putting pubes in
food
especially since i worked as a waiter
for five years i i
am exceptionally polite to food service
workers
because i've been on the other end for
so many years and um
and i tip really well so i'd like to
think that
my food doesn't get [ __ ] with uh on
on the rig but i've definitely got spit
in my food hundred percent
100 dude besides are you rude
no no same thing i've been a waiter for
a long time me and lena so we're always
same thing nice tip well but my cousin
who's the most picky eater and lena's uh
lena has a slight diet you know so
certain things because you know only
eating halal
causes her to send stuff back sometimes
and we always say that we're like 100
we're gonna
spit in this one wait so when you worked
in food service did you see anybody do
that i didn't see it but
at comerica park the tiger stadium in
michigan
some guy there's a video going around of
him spitting in the pizza
oh in the pizza sauce or something like
that wait is this what i have up here
right now
that's just yeah that's the story
there's uh so here's a story i got
comerica park worker charged thank god
after spitting
little caesars spitting on the food
little seizures
so this guy got charged that's awesome
yeah he did it on camera and he filmed
himself
genius his friend filmed him he said he
didn't know but
clearly if you're gonna not in the
marinara don't
film it a little extra flavor
well here we go little extra spice for
you so there's a video of him spitting
apparently on
trying to find it it's just some dude
upset well yeah that's probably the
the victim bro
douche ugh what come on
detroit baby well why would you film it
so here let's see what did they do to
deserve this because right now our
theory is that you have to piss them off
so let's see uh the person
filmed claiming he was wrongfully
terminated oh the homie filmed they got
recorded and he's mad
i was disgusted mad flabbergasted yada
yada yada
something tells me in the article
they're not going to give the guy
vacation
he says i had to use the bathroom but i
was actually looking for someone higher
up in the management to tell me what is
happening to pizza
okay yadda yadda
well the thing is this was at like the
baseball stadium
and i think they only served by the
slice so if he's wherever he's spitting
i feel like that's gonna
get to more than one person right if
it's right
it's gonna get split up
which is the scariest i mean i think
it's just oh lovebot is dead
okay so this is here the article says
that
he tried to return the pizza because he
said it was the wrong order
and um the employee thought he was lying
ah
just like what happened to ian i'm not
kidding i made that up
the tigers suck anyways i'm staying away
from marinara
for a while seriously you could hide
anything in the marinara
that's gross dude tiger oh [ __ ]
tigers i don't watch sports but i'll
tell you since i moved here
like all the california teams that won
the championship [ __ ] yeah
yeah good luck charm go dodgers what's
that gonna do with jizz in the mirror
yeah what no he was saying the tigers
suck oh he's just doing a little
baseball
okay i'm standing wide sports but okay
am i the only one left
uh yeah what you got okay now this one i
just want to
give up just kind of a
a disclaimer at the top because it's
about theodore
and obviously i love theater and there's
so many things i love about him
so this is all kind of just exaggerated
for the show
but there's a phenomenon there's so many
other good things that we love about him
but
he's hit what's called the terrible twos
he's uh
turning two in june the beginning of
june and me and either were like oh he's
not gonna
be because my mom and people always go
watch out for the terrible twos it's
like a
thing that it's a real thing they go
well and i was like the [ __ ] off shut up
about the terrible twos our kid's
perfect
well it's hair it's here
the terrible twos are here and they're
real
it's an actual phenomenon when they turn
about the age of two
they become more self-aware they become
emotional and they start exploring all
these new
sensations and kind of
self-determination right like they can
do things
they begin to understand the concept of
of no
too right like of like they testing i'm
not doing that or
yeah like they stopped being completely
compliant like an infant is
that punk has never been completely
compliant fair enough
so the thing that's going well okay just
for example this morning
and i had already prepared this last
night so this morning
we wake up at 5 30 to a loud crash
and i'm like oh my god what is going on
the dogs are barking
and in comes into our room theodore who
was in a crib
by the way so
he comes into our room carrying this big
crane toy
which by the way elo was battling with
him because he want didn't he wanted the
crane
in his bed to go to sleep and he was
like you can't have the clean because
it's all broken and sharp and spiky
and she's like you can't have the crane
it's dangerous i don't want you sleeping
with the crane
and he was throwing like a hissy fit he
was crying to the point it sounded like
he was gonna puke sometimes he cries
already pukes that happened once
brutal and so she's like no i'm not
giving in you can't have the crane when
you go to bed
so anyway she eventually got him to go
to bed so that's another thing is that
like
he'll throw a fit if he doesn't get his
way
and so this morning he walks in with the
crane in his hand
and he goes he goes like teddy
teddy hurt teddy got the crane he says
like teddy got the crane because the
crane was next to his bed
so he sue he kamikazed out of the crib
at 6 30 in the morning
which we kind of knew he was getting
there because you can convert the crib
to like a bed
because there's a certain point where
they get big enough they can launch over
the side
it's pretty tall i'm telling you it's
pretty tall and so just last night we're
like oh we should convert it like
tomorrow
and sure enough the same day he comes
kamikazing out of the crib
crashes on the ground and then comes
into our room at
5 30 he usually wakes up at like seven
so
with crane in hand and
he just gets into our bed with the crane
and he's like
teddy teddy crane teddy got the crane
and he's just
it was it was i couldn't believe it when
he just walked into our room like that i
was like oh
[ __ ] dude that's a new phase i mean
that's a whole new world right there
just the thought of him
being mobile to that degree yeah
oh my god so now i'm sure
once we convert his bed to like a actual
bed
he's gonna be it's gonna be like coming
in our bedroom and every
god ungodly hour just
walking around it's so weird to think
that he's just gonna be cruising around
he's also been doing this thing where he
bullies shredder specifically shredder
where he'll slap and kick him and pull
his hair and stuff
and shredder's so patient and good with
him but like
i'm always like you can't do that you
can't do that and especially when he
gets tired he starts getting super like
cranky and like uh
we call him trouble boy when he gets
tired he just stops listening and starts
like pouring water and
just getting into trouble to test us and
he will pull shredder
and he just laughs and laughs he thinks
it's so funny because shredder
will treader will be like
you know trying to get away and stuff
and he thinks it's so funny
but he's being like a picky eater all of
a sudden he doesn't want to eat anything
the only thing he wants to eat is pasta
that's it buttered pasta he's like
trisha this is
electrician but i was like dude you
can't live on pasta so i spent like from
the minute i get home
my whole night is now trying to feed
theodore i'll cook something he won't
eat it he just wants pasta
and i also gotta feed ela by the way
who's not that much [ __ ] easier to
feed
ela's mom when she was staying with with
us for a month she's like all you do is
cook for ila and theodore i was like
yeah that's my whole life when i get
home from work
i have no life and now the new thing too
is that he never
ever ever ever ever wants to sleep
never sleeping there's too much to do
during the day with peace and love
too much to do you know back even as
long as like a month ago it was like
sleep was like easy beautiful put him
down say good night peace and love
sleep for a good solid 12 hours and now
it's like
no sleep waking up early which is
it's nice he's stoked on life he loves
everything he's in a great mood he wants
to do stuff but it's like man it's tough
because
he should be in bed by like 6 37
and this dude's been staying up till
like 10 lately like he just does not go
to bed
oh and then he gets cranky
oh and this is a new thing too he now he
doesn't want to take a bath
he used to love bath time we got all
these crazy beautiful bath toys we got
like sharks and bubbles and
[ __ ] bubble bath and balls
we got this crazy cool new fishing toy
where it's got magnets
you throw it you bob and you do a magnet
and you catch a fish it's [ __ ]
amazing
and he's got like all of a sudden i
guess this is a thing that's common
in toddlers is they suddenly get a
phobia of
the bath specifically which is odd he
thinks
he always thinks there's poop in the
bath he goes poo
poop in the bath which i guess is common
uh
i didn't know that but this is a thing a
phenomenon toddlers think there's poop
in the bath and they want to get in the
bath we go there's the poop
there's no poop in the bath look at the
water there's no poop you think i would
tell you if there was poop
we empty it we wash it we fill it up
there's no poop
and he will not you know he went like
four days without a shower
because when you try to put him in he
just freaks out
and so it's been like a constant war
because we're like dude
i understand but like he starts to stink
his hair starts to stink
and we're like so he's gotten better
we've been giving up we usually we bathe
him every day
but he was he was so traumatized by this
thought that there's poop in the bath
he went four days without bathing and
then he we're just like dude we gotta
so i had to like hold his legs down and
either was
had like a washcloth and it was a whole
[ __ ] spectacle man trying to get this
kid to clean he's gotten better though
actually he has improved in the past few
days
so yeah it's
it's you learn a lot i mean fear of
bathing
called abulatophia is very common in
toddlers
shows up around age one to two it was so
weird because
he loved bath time and then one day
yeah panic that's fascinating and he
goes poop poop in the bath poop in the
bath
no poop in the bath
there's no poop it says during these
years of rapid brain growth toddlers
develop what seems like a hyper
awareness of their surroundings
their brains are literally lightening
lighting up with new information
so hey there's no poop in the bath what
can i say
we hope i pooped in the bath once when i
was a kid
i was in it with my brother too oh
we were bathing together and i took a
dump awesome
i'm assuming you were like three years a
few months ago
okay okay so
i gotta make it brown that being said
obviously you know
theodore's amazing he's doing amazing
he's doing great
i mean he's learning and he's growing so
fast he's so curious he loves everything
he's got this enthusiasm for life he's
just so happy every day
he's decided he loves me i go you know i
go over there and i do enemies and like
he uh he loves dan he does love it he
declares his love for me when i show up
he says i love you dan yeah it's so cute
yeah he does love dan he likes everyone
though he really likes
away from me he is amicable he really
loves people yeah i know he's he's
awesome but he loves dan
yeah he always goes in and from upstairs
yeah dan can't quite enunciate the d but
uh yeah
he calls me abc he does yeah
that's awesome yeah how is he with uh
auntie trisha
he loves he loves trisha auntie trisha
no he's not he loves trisha
no he was i was asking how is he towards
trump oh i thought you were saying he's
a good like antoinette
right and you know he started learning
to say thank you so he goes thank you
when you
give him like a bottle or anything you
do anything for me he goes thank you
what a guy and even says you're welcome
too sometimes i think him
class act and he by the way he's helpful
with chores now it's kind of epic like
if i have garbage i go go throw this can
you go throw this out for me
and i'll walk into the kitchen open the
drawer toss it out i'm like oh there you
go that's no real reason to have kids
right there
so it's just a lot of uh
chaos at the house right now it's hard
to imagine because he's such a
sweetheart
you know he is no he is a sweetheart
yeah i'm i'm highlighting that right
right he's not always like that it's
just there's moments where
it's chaotic i'll just say that you know
[Music]
that's all i got
thank you
um that's about it i hope this has been
a real off the rails experience i feel
like
i've we've specifically tried to go off
the rails today and
you want to keep that theme alive
no drama right we save that
for other episodes right this is off the
rails
it's about bodily harm it's about risk
of legal action
risk of divorce in abe's case
we're totally off the rails here yes sir
i hope you guys enjoyed and uh we'll see
you guys on friday
for after dark you know it's coming at
you live with evil klein
love that
[Music]
all right guys uh tata i shall see you
on friday thank you
[Music]
you